achievement in sound effects our Norman  one stall for Goldfinger  Robert Elbe rappin for the lively set  and the winner the winner is Norman one  stall for Goldfinger  ladies and gentlemen it's very difficult  to say thank you as sincerely as I'd  like to now but I'm a technician so  maybe I can leave the eloquence to the  artists that follow but on behalf of the  sound Department that I have worked with  and my production company and myself may  I thank you all very sincerely for this  tremendous honor and whatsmore may I  thank you for the opportunity of coming  to your wonderful country I think for my  wife and I this trip is going to be the  greatest experience of our lives thank  you very much